le retour de l'école obligatoire pour
tous ces parents d'ella chalonnais
l'attendait avec impatience
moi je trouve que c'est top mais bon les
enfants ils ont besoin d'être socialiser
avec les autres pendant deux mois et
demi on était dans un monde d'adultes et
je pense que c'est pas bien pour l'heure
pour leur développement personnel d'être
dans un monde d'adultes ils ont besoin
d'être dans un monde d'enfants
sauf que c'est un peu tard de reprendre
l'école de 22 c'est dommage pour les
enfants
alors il fallait reprendre plus tôt
c'est vrai que ça va être un soulagement
puis surtout pour les enfants de
retrouver leurs camarades mais moi
j'aurais été plus pour la rentrée en
septembre ce qui divise les parents
c'est la proche des grandes vacances il
ne resterait alors que quinze jours
d'école pour certains cela n'en vaut pas
la peine
mais pour le corps enseignant cette
reprise est primordial mais il ya de
nombreux élèves qui sont qui se sont
fortement éloignées de l'école pendant
la période du confinement et du déclin
finement pour des questions scolaires
mais aussi pour des questions de
socialisation sont en grand besoin de
collectif et un grand besoin d'écoles
bon mach 2 semaines on a que deux
semaines devant nous on fera avec ses
deux semaines mais je pense que cette
reprise de contact pour est salutaire
pour certains élèves interrogés sur
l'allégement du dispositif sanitaire le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
précise que le m séparant chaque élève
ne serait obligatoire quand espace fermé
les gestes barrière masque j'ai les
lavages des mains serait maintenu ses
déclarations de jean-michel blanquer
laisse perplexe le personnel de
l'éducation nationale je suis un petit
peu dubitatif puisqu'on dit l'école
normale j'entends dû en prendre à
l'école normale de façon normale mais en
même temps avec les gestes barrière donc
l'appartement on doit appliquer chez ce
barrière pour moi c'est pas tout à fait
une école normale
les détails du nouveau protocole seront
connus dans les 24 heures les personnels
n'auront alors que trois jours pour le
mettre en oeuvre et accueillir si tout
se passe bien
la totalité des élèves dès lundi
prochain